hi everyone
welcome to our talk on pythons in python
wildlife trade data analysis using
python
my name is andevan song and together
with my collaborator literal
we are excited to talk about wildlife
trade data analysis
using python
the global wildlife trade network is a
beast of a trade network
it is a multi-billion dollar industry
where millions of animals and plants are
traded within
and between countries for food medicine
pet trade gardens zoos and more
along with climate change deforestation
and fire
the wildlife trade is among the top
contributors to the global decline of
species
not only that the wildlife trade
facilitates the spread of disease around
the world which is bad for wildlife
livestock and humans the majority of
emerging
infectious diseases that are of concern
to humans
come from animals finally the wildlife
trade facilitates a species
invasion where non-native animals are
introduced into ecosystems which are
unable to adjust
to solve any of the problems surrounding
the wildlife trade
we need to have data about the trade so
where can we get information online
about the global wildlife trade
two great databases exist online
the fao or the food and agricultural
organization of the un
has cost scale data about trade between
countries
for example it tells you how many
non-food live animals are traded
but not the species traded on the other
hand
cities which is the convention of
international trade
in endangered species of wild flora and
fauna
has fine scale data which specifies
which species is being traded
it has over four shear data set with
more than 20 million
shipment records these can be downloaded
from the online database in
csv format to give you an example of
what a row of data look like
let's examine the screen capture in the
year 2013
a shipment of white-tailed eagles
scientific name
helioetis albacilla was traded to latvia
from the ukraine
along with this information we have
higher taxonomic information such
such as class aids which means it's a
bird
and falconiforms which tells us that
this is a group with falcons and related
birds
however the siteis database is a really
large database where one has to query
and download
multiple csvs to access the data and
many rows of data are missing crucial
information
in r there's an excellent existing
package called citiesdb which supports
the analysis of society's trade shipment
level data
and we want to create a similar package
in python
easy and reproducible access to this
database is useful for people who work
in
industry economics public health and
species conservation and these are
our target audience this past this
package is also useful for students for
example we recently conducted a course
at the university of rhode island for
network analysis of the wildlife trade
this package can also be useful for
researchers with more quantitative and
programming skills
as we provide streamlined access to
download this database
so here's what we had so far for our
package cites
i will describe the two main components
of this package first
data compilation and second data access
and analysis of the downloaded data
here is a flow chart representing the
steps that we take to produce a single
clean
data frame from online databases
pipes ids downloads the entire database
from the siteis trade database
at this web address in its raw phone
it consists of many cse files with
missing data
all these csv files are then merged into
a single data frame which then draws
from another database called
integrated taxonomic information systems
this allows us to computationally fill
in any blanks the data has for taxonomic
information
and correct any errors this also allows
first to use the most
updated taxonomic information for a
species as these
do change over time this complete data
frame with many of the blanks filled in
can then be saved as a csv file
so let's look at a realistic application
of this package
if you are a practitioner working in the
wildlife trade it is likely that you
would like to subset the data
by a certain characteristic for example
you might only be interested in trade
between say u.s and china
or you might be interested in only the
year 2008.
our package allows for easy filtration
of the data by your criteria of choice
in this example we will subset all data
rows with the genus
python which we all know are large
snakes that constrict their prey
specifically i want to extract all the
data about pythons imported into the usa
between
1996 and 2017.
as you can see in the code above
using my new subset of data i can then
go on to ask questions about the data
using my metric or statistic of choice
for example how many shipments are there
of different species of pythons
in the first chart in the bar chart you
can see how many shipments of eight
different species of pythons there are
in our data set
you could also plot a time series and
ask how has the shipment of these eight
different species
changed over the years from 1996 to
present
with just a few lines of codes one can
extract data from a huge database
subset and create descriptive statistics
with informative graphs
pi side uses work in progress as we all
are
we have four immediate goals first is
the improved handling of large
multi-gigabyte data sets with out of
core data frames
we also are designing an easy interface
for non-python users to be able to
subset and visualize
data we hope to incorporate network
analytic and visualization tools
which lend themselves very nicely to
understand this
sort of dyadic and relational data
finally we are interested to solicit
feedback from students and peers
and practitioners for additional useful
features for this package
that's all we have time for thank you
for listening and here is the link to
our piscis package on github
we invite you to peruse and collaborate
and look us up on social media as well
thank you very much